[Music]
yeah that's an exciting move I I think
we've seen in the original booth here
[Music]
tomorrow
mmm hot again our entire channels okay
[Music]
they said all is to go what roger
federer is to tennis huge headlines
around the world 60 million people
watched the game in China alone for us
it's the combination of 20 a dream okay
we beaten the world champion how can we
go further you know what could we learn
from that there are so many possible
application domains where creativity in
a different dimension to what humans
could do could be immensely valuable to
us
and the search time is getting better
and better as we go from for example 1
to 8 there's been a big chain of events
that followed on from all of the
excitement of alphago when we played
against Lisa doll we actually had a
system that had been trained on on human
data on all of the millions of games
that have been played by human experts
we eventually found a new algorithm a
much more elegant approach to the whole
system which actually stripped out all
of the human knowledge and just started
completely from scratch instead of
learning from human day to learn from
its own games and that became a project
which we called alpha zero zero meaning
having zero human knowledge in the loop
alpha zero is a kind of experiment in
how little knowledge can we put into
these systems and how quickly and
efficiently can they learn the next
stage was to make it in more general so
that it could play any two-player game
not just go but things like chess and
shogi which was Japanese chess and in
fact any kind of two-player perfect
formation game what we discovered was
that actually this exceeded all of our
expectations alpha zero could start in
the morning playing completely randomly
and then by TB superhuman level by
dinner it would be the strongest chess
entity there's ever been after about 8
or 9 hours it was strong enough to be
able to go out and defeat stop fish the
incumbent world champion a program which
was vastly stronger than deep blue the
program which had previously defeated
Kasparov so I called on my longtime
friend Matthew Sadler and Latasha Reagan
my two friends from when I used to play
chess myself so I knew that they would
be very excited to come in and have a
look at the system and it did cause a
big stir actually amongst the chess
players but when I first started looking
through the games I started thinking
it's quite interesting quite interesting
then there's just a couple of games that
when these were very exciting games very
attacking games I could see that alpha
zero was trying something different it's
like this young kid from deepest Russia
is sort of arriving and then suddenly
these
it doesn't have an engine like style
place like a human on fire it can really
try and evaluate things contextually in
the moment you know right now in this
particular position how valuable is my
night
traditional chess engines like stop fish
basically consists on a huge database of
rules alpha zero doesn't have any rules
it learns through experience and what I
found so interesting is because it
taught itself it might play the game in
a completely different way from the way
that we play it it's like a check on
everything that we've told ourselves as
humans since chess was devised really
and it feels like it's got a lot of
potential to do other things the next
step is actually to see if we can go
further
you know we we're trying to build
general algorithms not just to play
chess not just to play though the
world's a messy place and no one can
exactly write down the rules by which it
operates we can work with energy systems
in the real world with healthcare
systems in the real world what we'd like
to go with this is to push on to new
domains that no one's cracked and
actually use this approach to solve
those
so I'm hoping in future that we and
others will use alpha zero like
techniques to help us make faster
breakthroughs that I think society
desperately needs
[Music]